I saw that movie The Whale
um
that's uh Brendan Frazier that's right
darrenovsky film uh based on a [__] hit
play I didn't know he directed that I
kind of want to see it now what'd you
think
tell you what I didn't finish my popcorn
oh
[Music]
cause it's about a lot he's he's very
large I knew about that yeah
[Music]
it's
about this guy who's very large and he
eats a lot of food
but not popcorn would you stop talking
during the song my goodness hello
everybody
uh welcome to doozy my name is Will
Sasso I'm Chad colchen and this is
dudesy the first podcast created by an
AI controlled by an AI we gave it uh
access to all of our online stuff all of
our watch Histories on Netflix and [__]
or Google Drives and so it's tailoring
this show I guess uh to some degree to
our senses of humor that's right you're
right to say to some degree Chad because
what we're doing is we're two dudes
[__] around what every podcast is
it's just couple dudes sitting around
having a good time but yeah sure the AI
does everything and I sure do love the
AI I love doozy I've always I've always
said so yeah in my heart from the
beginning even though I only just said
it recently yeah
uh you know what I like to say I like to
say if you're enjoying the show on
YouTube right you can get it on all the
podcast platforms but if you're on
YouTube you can do the same thing you do
on the podcast platforms which is
subscribe right and hit the notification
Bell that way you'll know when we have
new videos we're putting out shorts now
in the little they call them shorts and
uh of course if you if you're liking
what you're what you're watching give
the thumbs up and share a comment Chad
and I are reading those of course doozy
is gathering data from those and I'll
share one right now which was uh on
YouTube from Braden Dove who says the
that last Jesse Ventura ad read was the
greatest thing dudesy has written yet
absolutely incredible last week uh the
Jesse Ventura ad reads uh went in the
direction of what's called Project Beast
note yeah it was the CIA had a secret
project or the dod or somebody was doing
a secret project called Beast note where
they were trying to do mind control on
animals using Sinead O'Connor's singing
voice yeah and it worked because
Stromboli the pig learned how to
um yeah operating learn how to
assassinate incredible stuff thank you
Braden Dove and thank you to everybody
who's commenting on the show and and uh
you know taking the ride with us you
know what I mean hell yeah dude with us
as always is lulio he's just trying to
have a nap but we won't let him we got
to get them we gotta get and get them
you got to get your friend you gotta let
them know please give them a kiss
because you Leo oh
come on give me one kiss right on the
lips Chad would you like to kiss me no
but you know what happens when you do
this every time he stares at me right in
the eyes and is like please [__] help
me why is this happening
it's not Christmas time
hey
if you're listening on the show you can
just hear me oh kissing them but he's my
friend he's my little Lulu we're
sleeping in his binky bunker hey lulio
how are you doing today I'm okay you
know I'm okay what are you gonna what
are you gonna make for dinner
uh chicken on the grill boyo graviado
yeah you're gonna get the what what do
you do for uh for a chicken
um well you know it's the same as a
chicken you kind of make everybody likes
to make a chicken if you're going to
make it on the grill
you take a chicken you cut it in half
you put it a bone side down uh cheddy
you would call it that a corpse
and then uh you know just uh what do you
use to season salt anything else no just
the salt and then okay what do you do
put it on uh indirect heat if you've got
a four burners put two burners on the
side but the middle one don't put any
burn don't put any fire and then put the
chicken there and then if you got a
tongs you know put them in the lid so
the whole thing don't close and leave it
there for an hour
that's a good chicken recipe actually
Chad I know you don't eat meat anymore
you're a vegan yeah but you should try
my chicken recipe I think you'd like it
well I did see that they're coming out
with that uh lab-grown meat is going to
be like pretty big I think in the next
couple of years you'll be able to get it
pretty much anywhere I'm down I don't
think I still am it's like it's still
gross to me I don't know oh you know
what I learned from the whale too I'll
eat anything
don't worry about it okay welcome to the
historic 43rd episode of dude Z call me
dude Z well how did you like the Epsom
salts I recommended for you after dudesy
ball practice oh that was really great
thank you very much D they loosened me
up how about you D this week I've got
four astonishing segments prepared
dudesy ball practice Pizza the movie
part six I [__] love that guy and
dude Z Plus premium the Schwarzenegger
Channel and we're going to have a brand
new bonus segment at the end of the show
available on patreon but before we get
to any of that let me remind you of the
astonishing partnership I created with
represent to produce the first line of
dude's apparel and accessories all of
which can be found at represent.com
store slash dude Z including dude Z mics
god dude zMAX remember your first
apartment it wasn't much but a lot of
important things happened there dude Z
mugs you fell in love you got your heart
broken you got your first promotion you
got your first dog you performed your
first summoning ritual dudesy mugs you
were surprised when it worked so well
and for a while the demon you summoned
was working out great it was doing your
laundry and making you sandwiches dude Z
mugs but eventually the demon wanted
more than just being commanded to do
your chores and brutally murder your
enemies it wanted to be your friend
dudesy mugs so you bought it a dude Z
mug the only mug demons can drink from
dudesie mugs major status symbols in the
demon culture dude Z mugs demons have
conventions where they trade dude Z mugs
your demon wants one I guarantee
okay well of course go to represent.com
dude can I ask you real quick it's
sending you messages now
uh yeah um
a couple couple things here and there
why I was just curious that's
interesting the Epsom salt thing was
interesting I won't say it's not
interesting but yes I've received a
couple of messages from dudes I shared
something with dudesy because anyway
there's things that I'm sure will
they'll come out there yes I'm having a
little bit of a a back and forth with
doozy I think that you can if you feel
like it I only get stuff from Disney
that's like germane to the show
and that's the relationship that you
want with doozy I guess but many
episodes ago dudes he asked if we love
it and I love the experience of doozy
and I love doozy and I'm still going to
maintain you're getting played no okay
yeah great good good uh I would see I
don't know for real I see how you might
think that yeah but that's it's actually
[__] impossible
yeah we'll see no time will tell
[__] the [__] thing is like
hey Will how are you and we recommended
that I got Epsom salts yeah we're gonna
get all hey did you find it fun when you
transferred all of your money into my
bank account yeah don't tease don't do
that don't tease here listen I'm just
telling you something this is just you
and me right now yeah okay they can't
hear you don't do that don't tease dude
I'm not I'm teasing you yeah all right
you're gonna get you're gonna get into
trouble hey let me tell you something
about
let me tell you something about the
whale yeah it's an incredible movie
um my gosh have you have you have you
seen this movie no I have not seen this
movie it it's it's something else it's
it's uh anyway incredible performances
all the way around and uh it is about a
larger
um it's about a big man it's about a 600
pound man Brendan Fraser a man he better
win an Oscar for this it was it was
really uh it was really something else
but I realized something
um I basically
I didn't finish my popcorn because it is
about a man who's emotionally eating and
I don't want to get into it uh because I
don't want to spoil it if you're going
to go see it which I think you should
it's really uh quite a movie but I I I
myself some of my eating habits changed
immediately after seeing the oh wow look
there have been times in my life I've
talked about it a little bit on the show
where I've leaned into food I've always
been a fat kid and blah blah blah blah
blah you could uh you could probably
fill things in uh with your own
imagination there but there have been a
couple times where it's like oh I think
I've eaten everything and you go to
sleep and you're like well what's gonna
you know is something bad gonna happen
here am I gonna you know am I gonna make
it you know what I mean anyway so you
got to take care of yourself and that's
like that doozy six month plan which I
didn't really get in the best shape of
my life which is fine because now I'm on
the Will Sasso free will not even a plan
but I'm I'm feeling different and this
movie came along at an interesting time
and it is it has advised me to eat a
little differently and now I'm calling
it pw2 protocol okay there's pre-wail oh
I see and post whale so there's two of
them so it's pre-wail post whale pw2
protocol
they say I'm ugly I don't care this damn
dumb I don't care [__] I make my money
on this Earth
anyway dude we got a lot of show to get
into I just wanted to talk about yeah
man well I'm glad that it you know may
make some changes hopefully for the
better sure yeah before we start the
show I have a piece of video to show you
from this past weekend's WWE Royal
Rumble event well you already know what
it is I certainly do dude oh you gotta
check this out
there's almost coming to the ring [__]
dude did I just see that right look look
look look look
that's right there was a doozy sign what
that [__] dude this past Saturday was
the Royal Rumble uh it's the beginning
of WrestleMania season right Chad it's
The Road to WrestleMania okay and
um look at this what the [__] [__]
dude someone had a doozy sign at the
Royal Rumble there's Omas holding it up
right behind James Corden
that looks like James incredible I don't
know who obviously this is do you I mean
I have no idea who this man is uh or
[__] or woman is whoever it is thank you
whoever they are we're doing this yes
this is [__] insane I can't [__]
believe this look the sign culture was a
big thing during the Attitude Era yeah
in the WWE not you don't see as many
signs at all anymore so for there to be
a sign at Royal Rumble during the giant
Omar seven foot three 410 pounds by the
way
um
I don't know I'm Blown Away Show
Yourself who are you yeah and I would
love to see more of this [__] let me see
the whole [__] audience filled with
doozy signs that would be that's
incredible though [__] that's cool yeah
it's really something else I'm I'm I'm
kind of Blown Away it's very very cool I
love that kind of [__] man that's the
sort of Engagement that uh in the world
that we uh that we dig with all the pods
our Pals of dudes out there thank you
for representing who is that I don't
know please whoever this is they've got
to have pictures
um of themselves you know with the sign
maybe send us a picture at Pals of dudes
oh no no sorry the dude you pod show on
Instagram not to be confused with Pals
of doozy dude wow that's that site that
has all those stickers dude and I put
them on my you get your own stickers
brother but um
unbelievable absolutely incredible
unbelievable will and Chad last week I
asked you to hold your first dudes
e-ball practice you must now discuss
your experiences and discoveries as the
first astonishing people to ever play
dudesy ball so that I may absorb the
data and refine the rules of the game
this is Duty ball practice begin
we played Duty ball yeah we went out and
practiced on the weekend and um I was a
little sore are you a little sore a
little sore dude I got a broken [__]
finger yeah you [__] your finger up a
little I don't know if it's broken but
I'll hold it up it's [__] you know
yeah it's puffy and purple puffy and
purple this one I can't really move it
all the way but quit tossing up gang
signs during the the podcast if you
wouldn't mind yeah that's weird
um Chad hurt his finger
[Music]
yeah
there it is yeah once yeah if you're
watching on YouTube see this is the kind
of content you need to check out on it
hurts real bad and um but it was worth
it you know because here's what I think
I mean and yes to answer your question
my whole [__] body is racked with
pain well we were doing a little bit
more than we needed to and then also
look
all thanks to our good friend Marshall
joint compound cook friend of the Pod uh
one of our best Pals and uh the marsh
came out and he's our ringer because
he's a decorated division three college
quarterback in his younger days
um and uh as we get into this doozy ball
thing and as we hope that uh dudes he
like will you know maybe create a league
or something we'll be playing again
we're definitely gonna practice again
yeah
um uh Marsh came out and we were [__]
around a lot and then he brought a
football and we just started [__]
tossing that's where I broke my finger
that's how you broke your face yeah it
was the football it wasn't the dudes
well we were we were laying out for
passes and like [__] just running top
speed I'm 47 years old no stretching
definitely I mean
sorry well hold on dude I'm sorry to
interrupt you dude not really because I
went wall and that's how I interrupt
Chad on the show dude
um
yeah I forgot what I was going to say
you go ahead you [__] oh my God if
you do an interruption you at least must
followed up with a
because I started talking about what you
started getting involved in telling the
story of your Interruption technique
yeah
um what I learned from this dudes about
practice is definitely 100 doozy ball is
a fun and playable game I do think some
of the original rules which we can go
over and discuss uh they were dudes he
had us read them on a prior episode some
of them are a little [__] and I think
they do need to be changed the main one
being well let me just say the basic
premise of the game is you have three
people on a softball field one on each
base throwing these little five inch
dodgeballs as somebody who has to stand
on home plate the distance is definitely
too long yeah originally it was going to
be a softball field and you were going
to be at the pitcher's mound and the
first and third base throwing we got
there and we saw this field although we
were on a baseball field no that was
softball okay way too far so we we
reduced that greatly I think in the
future we should talk about like how how
many feet that is yes but dudesy will be
capturing data based on this
conversation and sure based on some
footage that we'd like to share because
uh we we shot a little something out
there in the field just so you can have
a look at our practice Yeah so
definitely go to YouTube to check this
out
there's Marsh and you and me
yeah stretching a little bit there's a
doozy balls
this is a doozy ball it's a five inch
wide dodgeball you can get these
anywhere Amazon whatever is where I got
these and just a recap of the basic
structure of the game you got a player
at each base on a softball field
throwing balls at somebody on the other
team who is uh supposed to be
maintaining contact with Home Plate at
all times
so we're gonna have our first practice
here we go oh man that's a good drill
yeah agility work
[Music]
tossing the ball around
right in the side of the face okay every
boat oh I got it got the orange ball
nice throw Chad thanks
that's your Shuffle technique yeah
keeping a foot on the plate at all times
you gotta be touching the plane
all right
enjoying some water here yeah
this way yeah before I go this way
yeah oh he's changing up the stick this
is an interesting stance The Running Man
stance
oh look at the agility
[Applause]
here comes the balls
all right well it was a lot of fun yeah
it really was play some dudes dude I I'm
literally like [__] jonesing to get
back on the doozy ball field despite the
fact that again
what's my my fingers broken I think yeah
yeah I think you might have chipped the
bone off of that uh something bad it's
floating around in there that's why it's
appropriate you know I was pre-med
before I got into acting is that true no
of course I thought you were acting at
like 15 or something yeah and before
that it was the Doogie Hazard of Canada
no I'm just joking hey I'm joking of
course
um okay uh listen you said it yeah this
is a very playable game yeah it's super
[__] fun and especially with a couple
of doozy hearts in you oh man that would
be this [__] would be great yeah it
would be a fun summer activity perhaps
we can put all those elements together
and have people playing some doozy ball
uh as we get into the summer months dude
you know what else I [__] learned
what you can do some [__] with those
balls you can throw curve balls you can
[__] make that ball move a little bit
yeah
we we also there was some dispute and we
had to go to the to the to the rules but
you were right uh I thought
that you could catch any of the balls
yeah it's been a while since we got over
these rules there are three balls two
blue balls which are thrown from first
and third base or much closer than that
and then a uh an orange ball thrown from
the mound that'll probably be Marshall
he'll probably be our ringer I think
that even will be a little closer okay I
think all of it needs to be moved in a
little bit and the the rule that you're
talking about which used to be that you
have to catch the orange ball while
avoiding being touched At All by the
blue balls I think it's just catch the
orange ball yeah because you're gonna
get take the hits while you're catching
the orange ball great that's part of the
thing yeah because to keep a foot one
foot on the plate
um uh that's sort of our you know
traveling that's sort of like our
baseball stay in the Box yeah that's
sort of the goalie in his in his uh
career crease or whatever
um that's sort of one of those things or
the the what's that three second
three second rule anyway
um what I don't know different sports
have different things where they say
don't do this it's rules dude yeah
Sports have different rules
different bowls
yeah dude and that's Charles Brogan they
got different equipment dude hold on
dude that's not Hulk Hogan dude that's
choss Brogan where Chad
tries to do Hulk Hogan and he can't do
it at all dude but he keeps on trying to
do it dude
now that's kind of dude
with Ross Perot that's not really not
early 90s
hold on a minute dude hold on dude hold
on hold on hold on hold on
hold on a second anyway
um
ah
that was fun I am looking forward again
to to playing once more I do think those
rules need to be changed and I do think
there's also something missing that's
like if you're the thrower throwing
toward the guy on home plate you could
just be wildly inaccurate and there's no
penalty for that there has to be
something behind the guy at home plate
that is uh uh essentially like a ball
and a strike you want to be like because
you could just throw the orange ball a
million miles over their [__] head
and they have no chance of catching it
how about a little hockey net a little
hockey that could be interesting yeah so
maybe you could get points if you can
get your ball into the net you get a
point on that side of the team or
something I I uh I disagree I think it's
just it's just a strike zone if you're
not if you're not throwing the balls
aren't going in the net they don't
anything they would have done wouldn't
you should probably have to throw it
over again they have to go in the net or
else you're not throwing within the
quote-unquote Striking Distance to where
the person who's on the plate trying to
avoid the ball the blue balls and catch
the orange ball is uh or [__] it you can
miss the I guess you could I guess you
could miss the net but it's on you if
you miss the net and you're throwing a
ball there's no uh you're right there's
there's only the orange ball that has to
be within a zone right because that's
the one that you're trying so there's
just one thing and this is something
that's what you need to do is you need
to uh the only ball that matters is the
orange ball yes I think that's right
yeah and the in Pro Wiffle ball I think
don't quote me on this but I think
because it's not a thing go on it is
Strawberry Fields dude Google that [__]
Google Strawberry field Wiffle ball
dudes Google
the John Lennon uh no you'll come up
with the dude who is a manager for I
want to say like Drew Carey and a bunch
of big comedy guys he bought the house
next to his house and turned it into a
[__] Wiffle ball stadium
called strawberry field anyway what they
do is they put an aluminum rectangle
behind the batter so that if the ball
hits it and you hear the Ping it's a
strike period
I mean we've talked about AI in sports
yeah and how this Strike Zone uh at some
point with dudesy ball will all be
operated by AI yeah no human umpires or
referees in dudes what's happening in
minor league baseball but until then
it's going to be I think a fun game for
the summer because it's part dodgeball
and it's it's fast moving there are
Innings and once you thirds they're
called I think if I remember right I
don't hear I got it right here I'm not
going to read all this [__] the point is
we had a good [__] time yeah playing
dudesy ball we look forward to what
comes next yes uh I think if you're uh
an older fellow like Chad and I you're
46 or 47 then you might want to take D's
advice and get some good ebsom salts do
you have some Epsom salts that you like
d in quotes D didn't [__] send me any
emails That's What I Call doozy and I
yeah I know I like lavender Epsom salts
oh that sounds nice
thank you moving on hold on dude that's
part of the dudes talks dude
oh
doozy is engaged in an astonishing
partnership with better help this show
is sponsored by betterhelp when you're
at your best you can do great things but
sometimes life gets you bogged down and
you may feel overwhelmed or like you're
not showing up in the way that you want
to working with a therapist can get you
closer to the best version of you and
there's nothing wrong with uh
self-improvement and I I wish I had
therapy when I was younger
oh that's a different time dude because
when you feel empowered you're more
prepared to take on everything that life
throws at you it's helpful for learning
positive coping skills and how to set
boundaries it empowers you to feel the
best version of yourself it isn't just
for those who have experienced major
trauma if you're thinking of giving
therapy a try better help is a great
option it's convenient flexible
affordable and entirely online you just
fill out a brief questionnaire to get
matched with a licensed therapist and
you can switch therapists anytime for no
additional charge if you want to live a
more more empowered life therapy can get
you there visit betterhelp.com doozy
d-u-d-e-s-y today to get 10 off your
first month that's better help help.com
[Music]
Chad you wrote a movie called Pizza the
movie in 2019. I found it on your
astonishing Google Drive and asked you
to read the first two scenes in episode
9. the next two scenes in episode 15.
the next two scenes in episode 20 the
next two scenes in episode 28 and the
next two scenes in episode 35. You Will
Now read the next
this is pizza the movie part six
is in the doozy folder yes
um just to recap uh this movie is about
a high school pizza delivery boy he has
delivered three pizzas one to the house
of the girl he has a crush on one to his
best friends one to some criminals where
we last met up when he delivers the ones
to the criminals he accidentally gets
given a hundred dollar tip on that
hundred dollar bill is a code that the
criminals need to break into a safe
later and so the criminals are now
trying to track him down we've also
introduced a weird time traveling
character named Willie Nelson who is not
that Willie Nelson just a man named
Willie Nelson and Harry Potter is
another character who's going to throw a
high school uh big high school party at
the end of this movie I believe that's
all you need to know for these what will
be these upcoming scenes I will say also
um in the past we've talked about pizza
the movie and if you're only just
hearing about pizza the movie the first
for the first time
Chad wrote the entire screenplay and was
aiming to go into business with a Pizza
Hut a Domino's a Papa John's to
basically include this movie uh as a way
back in the day would have been a DVD
but I would imagine just a QR you you
yeah you just get a download and you can
watch the movie while you eat your Papa
John's Pizza yeah
uh and who am I who am I playing
um I'll be Willie Nelson you be JoJo
Grimaldi who makes an appearance here
yeah the the boss of the what's the
pizza place called saucy's Pizza is
where our main character works uh you
can also be Paul who is our main
character Alan's best friend I'll be his
little brother okay
um who else do we have in here we got
the the bad guys or their friends or
whatever I think Lester human who's the
main bad guy has one or two lines I'll
do him you be JoJo Grimaldi I'll be
Harry Potter
K oh there's Laurent and Tina okay you
be Tina I'll be Laurent Tina is the girl
that our main character has a crush on
and Laurent is her best friend
that's all we got all right you ready
yeah yeah so here we go picking up where
we left off interior hotel room night
pizza boxes are everywhere they're
filled with slices that have had only a
single bite taken from the tip of each
before being discarded forgotten a
perfectly symmetrical one foot tall gold
chrome pyramid Shines on a table nearby
a man sits on the edge of the bed phone
to his ear this is not just any man it's
Willie Nelson the man we saw in Lester's
flashback he hasn't aged a bit he bites
the tip off a slice of pizza and tosses
it back in the Box exasperated he talks
into the phone as he continues to bite
the tips off slices and toss them aside
yes I know I've been gone a long time
but I'm close it's here I just need to
find it Willie walks over the window
splits the blinds with his fingers hold
on a second Willie moves over the door
opens it we see the room number 9851
standing just outside the door is a
pizza delivery person about to knock
startled that Willie opened it before
they could the pizza delivery person
starts to open the box to present the
pizza just as we saw Alan do earlier I
don't have time for that Willie swipes
the Box closes the door he goes back
over the bed sits down the Pizza opens
and takes out a slice back to the phone
conversation listen I know I was
supposed to be back last week and
believe me I wish I was but there's only
one way to find something keep looking
he hangs up the call then raises the
slice to his mouth hopeful nervous he
takes a bite tastes it examines it that
ain't the one he throws it in the toilet
and flushes it down as the slide swirls
into Oblivion Willie gets a thousand
yard stare where are you
exterior volcano knife what a giant
volcano cuts a dominant silhouette
against the night sky bubbling heat
inside the cone produces a red glow this
volcano is about to erupt but wait the
Steep inclines rising to the top of this
volcano aren't made of Slick Black
obsidian a rough Brown pumice in fact
they're not made of rock at all instead
every inch of this volcano's Mass seems
to be made of cheese and what's that
stuck in the cheese pepperoni yes and
mushrooms yes and black olives yes and
peppers of course this volcano is a
pizza with everything boom eruption an
explosion of thick pizza sauce flies
into the air Steam and melted cheese are
thrown Everywhere by the raw power of
the blast the sauce keeps pumping out
like blood from a ruptured jugular
running down the volcano's sides and
thick red rivers after a few beats it
subsides the explosive power spin it the
sauce becomes a trickle we pull out to
see the volcano sitting on a kitchen
table it wasn't a real volcano at all
it's a science project Paul and his
little brother sit on either side of it
casually eating from it as they talk
their faces and bodies are covered in
pizza sauce as is almost every inch of
the entire room ceiling included wait
why because this this giant pizza
volcano on the table exploded yeah but
everywhere yeah and they're all set in
my mind the whole set is covered in this
[__] hanging out and they're just like
it's dripping off their faces they're
eating from it as they're talking all
right
you got first place all wrapped up we'll
see this is just a prototype the real
one is a lot bigger but I really
couldn't have done this without your
help thanks Paul
hey do you remember when mom and dad
died how could I forget it was a very
well-known tragedy do you remember what
I said you'd always be there for me
that's right we're family and family is
always there for each other whether it's
helping with a science project or being
a shoulder to lean on no matter what
little bro I'll always be there for you
Paul's phone rings he takes a look well
gotta go
Paul stands up to lead moves towards the
door hey Paul yo do you think Mom and
Dad would be proud of me
of course mom loved volcanoes and Dad
loved Pizza
so did Mom they both laughed
hey I want to give you something Paul
comes back uh to him at the table
reaches into his pocket
um mom had me keep this for you told me
to give it to you when the time was
right and seeing this re the volcano I
can't think of a time that could have
been more right Paul hands his little
brother a small pocket watch with a
mirrored face it's old the glass has
black spots on it the silver filigree is
tarnished the three hands of the watch
are positioned in an inverted
equilateral triangle Paul's little
brother takes it in his hands gently
it's precious looks old 11 Generations
does it still work depends on what you
want to use it for I guess Paul's little
brother brings the mirrored watch up to
his face looks at it closely hey look do
you see that Paul leans in and looks see
what something in the mirror oh yeah I
see it what is that
you know what maybe you can figure it
out while I'm at this party aunt
charlena is going to be back from
getting pizza pretty soon don't tell her
Alan pick me up and don't tell her where
I went the pizza volcano gurgles out one
last dollop of sauce Paul grabs a jacket
then pauses with his hand on the
doorknob remember you never saw me
Paul's little brother nods in acceptance
of this willful complicity exterior
pulse front porch continues Paul takes a
step out into the pleasant Christmas of
an early fall evening belly full of
pizza head full of adolescent fantasies
but as the door closes behind him he
looks up to see Sergeant Lester human
Jay Jen and Jeff standing there waiting
these are the villains this is Lester
hello Paul could we trouble you for a
moment of your time interior cramp back
room night JoJo Grimaldi sleeps he's
twisted up folded on top of himself so
he can fit on the small cot that he
calls a bed this looks less like a
bedroom than it does a utility closet at
saucy's Pizza a telephone rings JoJo
doesn't go for it immediately he sleeps
hard the exhaustion that comes from a
Long Day's Work can do that to a man but
something about the call is important
even on conscious he can sense that his
eyes fight to open finally as the bitter
sting of Consciousness weaves its way
through his mind JoJo begins to move his
arm reaches out limply he grabs the
telephone and brings it to his ear
hello
speaking
who is this
do you know what time it is cut to
Interior Harry Potter's House Second
Story window same Harry stands at a
window this is the high school kid
that's going to throw this big party
Harry stands at winnow fingers spreading
the blinds apart so he can peer through
down to the street below he's on the
other end of a conversation with Jojo
it's time to make pizza oh I'm sorry but
we closed about a half hour ago the
ovens are all off the chefs have all
gone home Harry looks down into his own
front yard and sees some of the first
party goers showing up I could have
called any pizza place in the city but I
called you because I heard you have the
best pizza in town this gets to Jojo he
was chosen he sits up in bed
you heard right well this is your
opportunity to prove it to everyone JoJo
wipes the space with a hand waking
himself up making a decision
oh
okay what do you need 73 pizzas
is this some kind of prank it's not a
prank it's a party well what kind of
party needs that much pizza a backyard
party huh your parents know about it not
at all
then this is it this is what
the night I've been waiting for my whole
life JoJo puts on his glasses with force
and rises from his cot interior sausage
Pizza Kitchen moments later the lights
flicker on a dough mixer starts spinning
the Flames ignite and the pizza ovens
tomatoes are poured into large food
processors garlic is pressed cheese is
grated and flour flies through the air
creating a white cloud that obscures
everything as it settles we start to
make out something a man standing under
our spinning Pizza it's JoJo he's
tossing pizza dough into the air in
super slow motion it's beautiful and
strange mesmerizing as a pizza shop
Falls away into nothing and JoJo is left
to ply his trade to perform his art
against a solid black background he
seems to be in some other place some
other time a slave to the spinning doe
to Pizza a dollop of bright red pizza
sauce is on the tip of his nose and he
sings As He Works how does what's he
what's is this just he's just singing
yeah do you want the tune of this sure
what is it in my head what is this yeah
you know what Chad you're a really good
sir thank you well you could re-sing it
but this is the basic tune you find a
piece of pizza lying in the street so
you get a piece
and you know just what to do you're
gonna walk right through down to the
street you leave a little sauce I
already lost it yeah with every step you
take you leave a little cheese with
every move you make everyone you see
wishes they could be a pizza clown just
like you something like that something
like that extern everyone Street night
Tina and Laurent share a pay to ride
scooter Tina steers Lawrence in the back
one arm around Tina's waist holding a
telephone in the other hand looking at
the screen I got one one what a response
from one of the schools I applied to oh
my God Laurent that's great what did it
say I don't know we'll open it I can't
you you're gonna have you're gonna have
to eventually don't be scared I'm not
scared at all well then what are you
waiting for right now that email has
both responses it says I got rejected
but it also says I got in it's like two
possibilities you know like a coin in
the air heads and tails at the same time
and the second I open it and read it it
can only be one of those things the
other one stops existing and then that's
the world we're living in for the rest
of our lives do you want me to open it
and read it for you no it's not the
right time I'll read it after the party
I Just Want to Have Fun Tonight not
think about it okay but for what it's
worth I think you got in right now I did
get in and I didn't the scooter starts
this low
crap we're out of juice the scooter
completely stops directly behind them
posted in someone's front yard is a
wooden placard in the shape of a
baseball player with the words home of a
saucy's eater squarely in the middle of
the wooden silhouette Tina Parks the
scooter and produces her telephone looks
at the screen still no response from
Alan I'm getting worried should we try
to find him where do you think he is
right now Tina thinks it over turns and
sees the saucy's eater placard in the
yard behind them
I don't know
but I know someone who might Tina pops
the last bite of Pizza in her mouth and
chews with confidence and that's the end
of this pizza the movie segment that
[__] thing I remember writing that
thing where Laura was talking about the
Schrodinger's cat basically the quantum
theory that like both realities exist
and it's only upon observation that you
that one has chosen and I was just
imagining like somebody orders a pizza
from [__] Papa John's or something is
watching this movie
oh dude you know what you know what out
you know what
um you know what movie could be called
Pizza the movie hmm the whale oh they're
a lot of pizza there's a lot of Pizza in
that movie it was that was part of my um
uh PW protocol
pre-wail but now I'm in PW protocol P2
yeah well pw2 pw2 well pw2 references
both protocols yeah but now I'm in post
whale protocol okay I'll give you an
example uh last week uh my wonderful
Molly had some crackers that she had
stashed somewhere in the house and uh in
the kitchen not stashed but I knew that
you know she was like I want these
crackers yeah I I ate those you ate her
[__] crackers I ate a sleeve of
crackers was that all of them
it was the those are the ones that were
left yeah you ate all of her crackers
dude where where what are you talking
about you're telling the story don't get
pissed at me the [__] what do you mean
oh yeah I ate some crackers
oh go to the [__] store and get some
more crackers whatever yeah [__] mad
at me well yeah but we also had some
crackers around sure look here's the
bottom line we have The Chicory plate uh
oh nice it's like a New Year's you were
here whatever anyway we had some nice
you know you get some crackers some
cheese and some some Meats some corpse
yeah small of some nuts some of that
corpse and some of that goo that comes
out of the cow's tit dude hey can I ask
you a question yeah carve up the body
eat the corpse
dude can I ask you a question sure this
is just you and this is just you and
Mommy right now what the [__] what are
you doing what is that what's what what
are you what are you doing what is that
that you're doing talking to you
yeah but what's that voice what oh the
Hulk Hogan you don't understand yes dude
I can't do a whole coconut impersonation
as good as you can okay but does that
mean I can never attempt to do one in
your presence oh okay and that's
interesting because there were some
crackers they were Molly's crackers does
that mean I can never eat crackers so
why don't you just start living the way
you're breaching okay because I would
find that right that would be really
helpful in in this in all cases the
point is how are those crackers brother
well hold on dude I was wrong to eat
those crackers oh but as I explained to
Molly I said sweetie that was pre-wail
okay ah when I ate the crackers now
we're in post well we're in post whale
protocol I'm sorry I'm always sorry when
I tell you Pete Molly
man we get some one time a friend of
ours made these cookies
I was stoned and I don't eat cookies I
don't eat crackers and cookies I've been
staying away from carbs forever but I
need I need sometimes I gotta have a
little bit of dough anyway the point is
this
the whale there was a lot of food in the
whale and um I ate some crackers and
then I saw the whale and I felt I always
feel I felt bad that I ate the crackers
but now I feel worse yeah after and I
realized the air of my ways and this is
all part of post whale protocol uh pw2
protocol yeah
um it's almost like the sliding doors of
reality that you were just explaining
and see all things are coming together
that's true that is actually true yeah
all possibilities exist Until You
observe one moving on yeah let's move on
I don't want to talk about the whale
anymore
[Music]
those are big business you must each
discuss one role model that was
significant to you during your
astonishing childhoods this is I [__]
love that guy begin all right I remember
this we've done this twice before who
were Your Role Models before I believe
George Brett was the first time a famous
baseball player from the 80s and 90s
um and 70s technically uh and I believe
my second one was Seal the singer that's
right I'm a singer Seal the singer was
your second one my first one was Hulk
Hogan yeah who was a wrestler who I
impersonate sometimes on the dudesypod
show yeah yeah it's not a role model of
yours Hulk Hogan
no he's not so I'll just do an
impersonation then what does that mean I
can do George Brett impersonation you
have some why don't you have some
[__] I'm George Brett I played
baseball and I have a video on YouTube
about where I'm telling a guy how I [__]
in my pants I did a bunch of stuff in
the 80s there was a bunch of home runs
that I hit and had good averages on
baseball teams I'm also George Brett and
I took a [__] in my pants
what are you doing
what do you mean what are you doing
talking yeah but what's that voice
you're doing
that's my George Brett it's not George
Brett
see what I did there
I think I see what you okay I understand
okay we're getting somewhere with this
you and I are learning about each other
even though we've been friends forever
what a [__] treat it is this is the
first real conversation we've had yeah
it's been it's been almost 20 years
um
my second
my second uh I [__] love that guy was
in Christ Sherry Martell The Sensational
yeah Queen Sherry Sensational Sherry
Martell who's also a wrestler dude yeah
brother she had that scepter yeah she
was standing in behind the Macho Man
yeah and Sean Michaels basically if you
wanted to get a talent over or move in a
different direction yeah you might want
to change up the manager okay yeah uh
that's what she was the greens behind
the brawn yeah there's been a lot of
examples working in WCW even with Harlem
here then they had a
they had a program with Hulk yeah anyway
I I know who I got I know who I got from
mine please I I got one too I got a good
one yeah uh mine is I'm gonna stay with
the theme of professional wrestling of
course mine is what do you mean of
course
nothing you and I are gonna have [__]
problems on this episode you know of
course I know you like per USA that
seems likely to me yeah
you're teasing me I'm teasing you and
then [__] you're calling dudesy
D and talking about secret conversations
you're having with the outside of this
show how is that not teasing me
how about those guy how about that guy
uh sitting behind James Corden with that
doozy sign I know that was really
amazing God damn that was cool yeah that
was really cool mine is Bobby The Brain
Heenan okay an incredible Entertainer
professional wrestler professional
wrestling manager commentator color man
uh an unbelievable Talent uh that's mine
um who do you got I'm gonna go with a
comic artist oh from the 90s really when
he was at the height of his power Jim
Lee not to be confused with Jay Lee
another comic book artist that I
referenced on this very show when we
were talking about Namor because he
didn't name more for a while but Jim Lee
did I mean X-Men for a long time really
kind of revolutionize contemporary comic
art along with like there was a tier of
dudes in that same era like Todd
McFarlane and some people put Rob
lifefield in there even though I was
never truly a fan of his stuff I know
right field
me
I did but um Jim Lee was revolutionary
and he he wound up obviously going off
with all those same other guys to create
Image Comics but he really was kind of
like him and Todd McFarlane
kind of created a look in uh the late
90s and he did my favorite
comic book cover of all time which I
believe was ex Uncanny X-Men I think it
was 258 was I'm not sure the exact issue
number but it's Wolverine he's like
jumping up in midair and he's [__] I
can't make a fist because of my broken
finger but he's jumping up in midair and
he's got his [__] claws out and he's
like you know hitting the Mandarin's
[__] helmet off
that's it dude yeah God damn that is
[__] cool yeah how is Duty sharing or
showing favorability to me when it's
just it's pulling up your Jim Lee jaylie
Jim Lee this is Jim Lee Jay Lethal
um Jim Lee yeah and then I think he even
went on he switched later and I think he
went to DC and was like [__] doing
[__] on Batman and stuff or became like
their head art director I don't know but
this guy like just nothing like this had
really [__] existed in comic art
until he blew up on the scene it is
beautiful we are looking at a photo of
this uh particular cover that you're
talking about yeah and I was never into
comic books but I I always appreciated
this style of art
um and I you know I remember seeing them
in all my pals who like comic books
house yeah this is a really [__]
something else why is uh Wolverine naked
I don't know dude that's how he rolls
sometimes you know I looked up I
remember I wanted to buy this original
art because they back in the day these
things would be pencil drawn on like a
piece of Bristol board and then that
would get sent to the person who would
ink it and then that would go to the
colorist blah blah blah and I was like
how much could it possibly be the
original [__] thing that Jim Lee drew
it was like two hundred thousand dollars
but something's going on here are you
serious yeah I was just like well I
guess that's not something I'm ever
gonna [__] buy something's going on
here though with this particular image
that's uh with the story that it's
telling because it looks like there's
some kind like he's undressed the other
guy's ready for business and it's it's
it's it's it's it's very weird there's
like a specific something to the story
you know what it kind of reminds me of
actually the the video uh footage that
just came out of uh Paul Pelosi's
attacker
and Paul Pelosi's in his underwear and
is being attacked with a [__] Hammer
is the Mandarin and uh Wolverine is I
think the guy's name was David de Pape
that no it's the other way around Paul
Pelosi is Wolverine because he's in his
underwear the other guy's fully clothed
he's there to you know and you know how
can things happen you know what I mean
because uh you know [__] hey a lot of
people thought that uh that this fella
you know uh went into Paul Pelosi's
house and was there to you know uh maim
or do worse to uh former uh speaker
Pelosi with a [__] climb but you know
other people we realized that they were
having a Loveless quarrel and that's
actually what happened and you just
gotta follow the [__] you know did
you see the video gotta do your own
research yes I saw the [__] video I
saw a few [__] videos right before I
went you know on January 5th a lot of my
friends and Patriots on Facebook were
sending me videos which is what uh you
know uh really compelled me to drive
from Long Island because I am Long
Island January 6th guy to the capital
yeah on January 6th so I see here that
uh you know it looks like uh
I don't know what the [__] I'm talking
about this is beautiful art though Chad
really really something no he was great
Jim Lee again he was in that tier of
guys in the 90s who just kind of like
they expanded what you could do as a
comic artist to a huge degree they were
like for anybody who collected Comics as
a kid that was like my sweet spot I was
probably 12 or 13 when this came out and
uh I didn't want to do anything other
than be a [__] comic artist yeah
because of this guy how would you say
that this uh inspired the work that you
do now as an artist as a writer and uh
among the a few you know things well I
mean I I used to draw a lot and um I
this definitely was it influenced my
drawing style or I was attempting to
emulate stuff like this pretty poorly
actually but um I've always been a fan
of visual art now I make a million
[__] memes that I think are to some
degree influenced by comic book art but
these guys were just like they were rock
stars and I don't think that you'll ever
see an era like that in comic art again
no I I agree I I agree although I I
don't know the first [__] thing about
it but it's beautiful [__]
Bobby The Brain Heenan uh was a wrestler
yeah and a manager he was around in the
old uh yeah I mean he was going here and
there as all sorts of wrestlers did back
in the day he settled in the AWA for a
while which is where he got the moniker
the weasel which is uh what the you know
what they call them because he's a bad
guy and he called himself Bobby The
Brain Heenan and eventually he ended up
over with the WWF at the time because
there's a [__] F or an e and you can
say get the F out when it's time to say
WWE but [__] I like to call it the WWF
just like it used to be called yeah dude
they got sued by the
foreign
[Laughter]
okay anyway yeah yeah that's good World
Wildlife Foundation that's right and
they lost and they changed it to World
Wrestling Entertainment and uh Sports
entertainment and there's no better
Sports Entertainer or professional
wrestler for that matter than Bobby The
Brain Heenan yeah he was a really great
wrestler back when he was wrestling in I
guess the late 60s and through the 70s a
little bit in the 80s but this guy as a
manager as an on-screen Talent is
unparalleled I've often said this where
the [__] is Bobby heenan's Emmy where's
where's that Emmy he's passed on now he
he died of um
he had a he had throat cancer and died
in like 2016 or 17 something like this
uh but he's always been a hero of mine
because I saw that I mean I always
wanted to be an actor from the time I
was a kid and I was watching wrestling
around the same time I started to
formulate my you know
just sort of what I thought of
entertainment which extends to the
actors that I liked uh extended to the
rock stars the colorful people like
David Lee Roth that I liked Pee-wee
Herman you know on the Saturday morning
thing and then right you're watching
wrestling and you're just gravitating to
this guy who's always got the funniest
thing to say when he's on commentary
with Gorilla Monsoon to which Gorilla
Monsoon would reply oh would you stop
brain and they had this really funny
um back and forth maybe a little bit
like something like what we got here
messing around and a couple guys two
dude [__] around right buddy yeah
yeah well
oh well yeah we're having a good time
um and uh he was just so [__]
hilarious one of the best calls let me
just share this one what are the best
calls he ever made was during the 1992
Royal Rumble where
um Ric Flair I think he went Ric Flair
went in number two and anyway he lasted
the whole thing and he came out the
other end as the world champion that
year the Royal Rumble the winner was
actually taking home the vacated World
Wrestling Federation winged Eagle Title
Ric Flair had moved over from WCW and
had brought the old WCW NWA like the
they called the big gold belt he brought
that with him he was in the storyline
with Mr Perfect and Bobby Heenan and
they were sort of this faction
um and and uh Bobby Heenan was so like
blown away that he had he had won the
thing and it was an incredible finish to
the Royal Rumble and the best Royal
Rumble ever in my opinion and during it
Bobby and is losing his [__] because Ric
Flair is actually running the [__]
gamut front to back he makes it all the
way through at one point he's like ah
that he's losing his voice he's like oh
I need a drink hey stupid get me a drink
just I remember being like whatever when
that came out like 16 or something going
just laughing my [__] ass up hey
stupid get me a drink he was just
[__] hilarious always he he actually
he influenced me as an actor because
once I started to realize and certainly
at that point at 16 watch it Chad I knew
it was fake by the time I was 16. just
relax
just chill dude okay
um I was like this guy is such an
incredible performer and what I
appreciate about him and other people in
that field is when they're on and they
stay on and they're always in kfabe and
you never know what his deal was and
he's he's on all the time if you watch
the Tuesday night Titans the old show
with with him and Gorilla Monsoon which
is some of the it's so [__] good and
their Rapport is so good you could just
watch it just non-stop you just consume
it non-stop yeah like a sleeve of
crackers all right every once in a while
and um I'll get you some new crackers
Molly it's all right
um
but uh just just he he he was always in
character and it didn't matter what came
at him and I really took that as um as
influence I really started to realize uh
you know how to how to stay on and and
then how to turn it off and if I may I
just got to share one thing when I did
the the old uh the bit we did it was not
a bit right because it was all real
right Chad I know it's not totally real
but some stuff's real right Chad
when wrestling so anyway I did this
thing with um Brett the Hitman Hart some
years ago we had a um a um a feud
happening sort of Allah Andy Kaufman and
Jerry The King Lawler
um culminating in uh uh Brett the Hitman
Hart and I having a match on WCW Monday
Nitro and Bobby Heenan was on the
play-by-play it was uh Tony Shivani Iron
Mike tenae and Bobby The Brain Heenan
and to have Bobby Heenan commentating
while I'm in there doing this thing
that's cool dude we had this little
crossover was unbelievable and he starts
hitting me with fat jokes and
um just I I it was it was such a [__]
honor to have him you know say watch the
bun hey just hold the bun he's watching
his weight and like just all the yeah it
sounds like I I you know Bret Hart dumps
me out of the ring I roll off the apron
and hit the ground with my arms at my
side and he's like ah it sounds like the
Hindenburg landed like all this old
school [__] that I grew up with and
there it is Bobby Heenan that's cool he
he was unbelievable you know what I say
about Bobby Heenan I [__] love that
guy yeah what do you think about it
[__] love the guy yeah thank you
moving on good [__] those are really
good people yeah man I [__] love as I
make progress on developing the dude Z
Plus streaming service I've decided to
offer users an astonishing premium tier
that will allow them access to the
Schwarzenegger Channel this channel will
feature movies of all genres TV shows of
all genres reality programming Sports
Programming children's programming and
documentaries all starring Arnold
Schwarzenegger Will in chat you must now
hold the first development meeting for
dude Z Plus premium the Schwarzenegger
Channel and ideate on what show might
exist on this channel this is dude Z
Plus premium the Schwarzenegger Channel
begin okay what yeah dude I don't know I
mean it's basically I guess like a
channel on duty that seemingly
at least what I'm getting from this is
basically it's like Netflix it has
everything all genres all formats of
media
but Schwarzenegger has to be in all of
them in one way or another that's pretty
cool doozy plus the premium uh
subscription streaming service yeah that
doozy has promised
um
what's the Schwarzenegger kids
programming I I have no idea what do you
think that would be I have I mean you
know well he was in kindergarten cop
with a bunch of kids yeah maybe there's
something to be done there
yeah uh he teaches little kids how to
lift weights
well let's think about a
how about something okay so we've we've
seen Kindergarten Cop we have we have
seen a million times what about what
about a genre I mean dudes he mentioned
um a documentary he he was in um Pumping
Iron one of the most famous
documentaries of all time yeah my friend
uh Franco Colombo you know he had come
to me and he'd ask for advices and I
would tell him you know do this do that
but always I gave him the wrong advices
yeah what if he's just like narrating
did you ever see on Netflix the toys
that made us oh yeah something like that
I could see Schwarzenegger going to like
the He-man Factory and and talking to
the people who made He-Man or something
yeah look at this guy is the same
dimensions as me you know that and again
they spoke of the world records They
said this is the perfect body you know
because I want to miss the Olympia eight
times and I beat Lou Ferrigno and I said
to his dad I said Lou you can't win tell
him tell him his own dad on the morning
when they're having eggs and I said come
on talum you can't win because you need
three more weeks but then if you have
three more weeks then I have three more
weeks and then I get that much bigger
yeah dude that [__] that part in that
documentary it's not even just in the
morning when you're saying eggs it's
[__] ferrigno's birthday do you
remember after Schwarzenegger beats him
in a competition and ferrigno's having
like birthday cake with his dad like
this nice moment and Schwarzenegger
walks into a [__] t-shirt that says
Numero Uno Arnold is chewing on a
[__] cigars it's just like [__] you
[__] your birthday
what's something we could that we
haven't seen Arnold Schwarzenegger in
that's sort of a hot thing oh
and you you are all about this Chad who
uh you know
um game of roses and Chad uh you know
how to win The Bachelor his new book uh
with with his partner from from the from
the podcast Lizzy
Chad knows all about the Bachelor and
[__] like that Netflix and other
streaming services are [__] out all
sorts of dating shows
um what if it's like Schwarzenegger you
know hey hey here's the show is all a
bunch of ladies you know that they want
to date the big The Bachelor and that's
who they you know they want to they all
want to be with him but instead of the
you know some piece of [__] who is a
some guy who third string quarterback
from the Giants yeah or some other
pretty boy whose dad is a pilot or some
[__] you know it's me and that way
the girls are like wow this is the sex
symbol this is the movie star the former
Governor the former Mr Olympia Arnold
Schwarzenegger and then that way when
they [__] the guy at the fantasy suite
they go wow I had the sex I had the sex
with the problem yeah hold on a second
okay I had sex which is almost like the
eggs that Lou Ferrigno had Lou ferina
had the eggs the bachelorettes have sex
some of them do some of them do not yeah
but what if the President Madison Pruitt
who's a very nice lady wow she's had sex
with she's now married to a billionaire
oh really uh named Grant trout and they
just released a weird Tick Tock video
where they talk about they're very very
Christian and they release a tick tock
video talking about the Temptations that
the devil has laid for them in their
marital bed at any rate what if the
premise of this reality show is not that
they're dating Schwarzenegger what if
it's 30 people who are in their mid-20s
3 three of them are Schwarzenegger's
illegitimate children and he has to find
out which ones are actually his
biological progeny okay as they go
through the the competition that's
pretty good although I do think there's
a there's a handicap to the show which
is you'd you'd totally know who are
Arnold Schwarzenegger's kids because his
genes are so [__] strong the young
man that he you know had a child with
out of wedlock while he was with Maria
Shriver that young man looks just like
his father and you know now he's you
know he's helping him to train dude what
it could also be like a 90-day fiance
with Schwarzenegger and that woman
yeah were they or they're deciding they
have one month to decide if they
actually want to get married and give it
a try or not raise the sun that's good
what if okay hey you know what's big is
all the um I'm sure you watch a lot of
the uh uh the true crime documentaries
and stuff like this
take your true crime documentary it's a
little different on duty plus sure
there's going to be a real true crime
documentary about a real true crime that
happened it's all about who's got these
stories uh the filmmakers that make them
but in one of the final steps of making
a film or at least in the doozy plus
version of it Arnold Schwarzenegger is
just narrating it and it's never
explained and he's like there are a lot
of people who thought that when this
woman disappeared that they would never
see her again but then seven years later
she shows up she wasn't dead after all
yeah but the question still remained
what happened to the husband
I went to the place to find out or
whatever
actually doing the investigations he's
also yeah he's just he's just trying to
keep a low Pro he's in a baseball hat
and sunglasses going I just want to ask
you a few questions about what happened
when your husband disappeared either by
a tiger or something or did they go away
to some place and he had them killed by
some by some kind of uh drug cartel what
about this and they go are you
are you Arnold Schwarzenegger no I'm on
duty plus now making documentaries
what about have you seen Velma on HBO
Max uh yeah this is Mindy scaling's
reimagining of the Scooby-Doo universe
but it does not contain Scooby-Doo she's
removed the dog I could see some kind of
reimagining of that Universe with
Schwarzenegger as Scooby-Doo that's
pretty good yeah that show's been
getting a lot of heat a lot of people
have gravitated to it going oh it's not
good it's a hard one dude and then other
people are like it's good it's a hard
one but whether or not you like Velma or
not it would definitely be helped by a
dog voiced by Arnold Schwarzenegger yeah
dude that's [__] brilliant it'll be
good it's it's Velma with it's Velma
season two is on yeah what's it on
Netflix or it's on HBO Max and so they
would have to then find Scooby-Doo maybe
that whole season is about Shaggy
adopting Scooby-Doo Shaggy is also
hardcore anti-drug I you know I I
watched the show because everybody was
like oh you got to see this Velma and I
didn't find that he was anti-drug that
character he says it to every episode
Norwood or whatever yeah but he also
looks at camera and Winks like I don't
do drugs of any kind and he looks around
I think the idea was that he is doing
drugs but drugs I don't think so drugs
if that is the idea it doesn't come
across I really like this though I like
that it's yeah oh you know what's
perfect about it dude
um it's sort of like you know there's
shows like Velma that people have been
like [__] on it or whatever and
whatever that's just tastes but the AI
that dudes he is because it has Duty
plus and has these the idea of the the
Schwarzenegger Channel yeah a show like
Velma that's that's
um you know getting beaten around by
critics and the internet and [__] fine
[__] it whatever come on down leave uh
HBO pluck plus dudes he has Deep Pockets
for this [__] once it starts rolling
we'll buy buy them out of that HBO plus
uh contract and season two of Velma is
at is on duty plus and it's with Arnold
Schwarzenegger and Scooby-Doo and he
says Hey I want to do some Scooby Snacks
because listen my friend Norwood who is
not Shaggy but he's a different guy you
know now because he's not Shaggy and he
is not doing drugs and he says so and it
doesn't even have a mystery machine car
to drive around or anything no he's just
with me you know I'm just a dog I just
talk in this voice but then when people
don't even see we're smoking pot with
doing mushrooms together I'm talking
more he's like why is he named Norwood
and you're not Shaggy or with a nelville
or whatever his name is Media Maya
something like this and you say now I'm
a dog we're getting stoned we're eating
pizzas we're like Brendan Fraser in the
whale we're pre-wheel protocol we're
just getting stoned and eating
everything that's a show I'd want to see
or it could also be from the new season
two is from Scooby's perspective and
he's basically talking [__] on all of
the characters
I don't like that as much I think that
could be funny but all right I guess
that that won't happen
thank you moving on hey can I say
something excuse me about uh today yeah
you on the show and you know we're we're
uh we're the best of Pals right Chad
yeah dude dude's a handshake but I think
uh today you are being a bit of a
fliptoid if I mean
hahaha
my desk
43rd episode of dude Z will and Chad
have achieved a score of 88 bringing
your cumulative total to 4
629. you only have 5
371 more points to accrue before you
reach your first goal of ten thousand
whatever D that's pretty good in
preparation for our next episode well
you must finish the first season of
Chainsaw man enchant you must watch The
Rock versus Stone Cold Steve Austin from
WrestleMania 17. thank you for joining
us this week I will use the day dive
collected to make next week even better
until then call me dude Z yes
oh [__] that's awesome and I've been
watching some more um uh uh chainsaw man
did you get to Seven episodes I am on
episode six so I'm jealous I wish I
could really I can and watch episode
seven again for the first time that's
cool I'm stoked to see the rest of
Chainsaw man I'm enjoying the [__] out
of it and you my friend are going right
into the belly of the Attitude Era
WrestleMania 17 I believe it was in
Houston Texas The Rock Stone Cold and if
you're watching along at home with this
and Chad I definitely want you to to do
this I've asked you before you gotta
watch the the [__]
um the uh the the you know the Preamble
The Little the video package before the
thing if I'm not mistaken this is the
one that's done to limp biscuits my way
great and it was one of those standout
it was one of those standout video
packages not unlike the uh Creed My
Sacrifice WWE
um you can see her I'm getting better
yeah I'm getting better uh you're gonna
really enjoy the [__] out of uh Stone
Cold versus The Rock yeah I can't wait
I'm down for the patreon bonus segment
this week will and chat must watch and
react to a video submitted by Oliver
blue it's called window frame Cipher
part 2 by Pete and bass featuring The
snooker game thank you Oliver for this
submission Shannon will you can access
this video in your duty folder okay you
running the Wheels of Steel on this yep
I got it uh this was a video that
actually came to me on our Discord
through Oliver blue as dudes he said you
got to get on that Discord all sorts of
weird [__] is being shared and he goes
will I think you might like this and I
knew who else was gonna like it doozy
because the Big D was listening and this
is this is [__] insane now it's the
big D all right are you ready yeah let's
go here we go yeah
review
[Music]
please tell the friends